[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur lcp la seule
émission qui allie alimentation
agriculture écologie mais aussi
politique et cette semaine nous recevons
françois de rugy c'est vous qui allez
passer sur le grill est avec moi pour
présenter cette émission jean pierre
montanay bonjour jean pierre bonjour
brigitte bonjour françois de rugy
bonjour bonjour françois de rugy vous
êtes député de loire atlantique depuis
2007 trois mandats que vous avez
successivement mis au service de
l'écologie vous qui avez débuté à
génération écologie puis les verts puis
europe ecologie les verts avant de
fonder votre propre mouvement le parti
écologiste vous affichez donc la couleur
sous françois hollande vous co présidé
le premier groupe écologiste à
l'assemblée candidat à la primaire de la
gauche en 2017 vous êtes éliminé au
profit de benoît hamon mais vous
déciderez finalement de soutenir
emmanuel macron vous devenez ensuite
président de l'assemblée nationale un an
plus tard vous intéresser au ministère
de la transition écologique pour
remplacer au pied levé nicolas hulot
démissionnaire au bout de huit mois vous
tombez sur des révélations de mediapart
on vous reproche finalement trois dîners
dont l'un avec du homard au menu comme
quoi c'est toujours très politique le
choix du menu jean-pierre effectivement
et donc menu à message aujourd'hui avec
du breton pur juin kika farce et en
dessert un adepte ou non plus dans le
dos ou des plats la pénurie d'huile de
tournesol dû au conflit en ukraine
incite les agriculteurs à augmenter leur
production d'oléagineux
dans les pieds dans le plat les
agriculteurs lutte contre la sécheresse
avec l'agroforesterie késako réponse
avec un reportage dans le finistère
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidences
alors fort soit de rugy vous avez donc
décidé de vous retirer de la vie
politique alors coup de bluff ou vrai
départ est bien pour ceux qui
s'interrogent encore je le rassure qu'il
n'y a plus de suspense et ce qui me fait
dire ça c'est votre menu du jour choisi
ici à l'assemblée votre maison pour
cette émission et oui les jeux sont
faits le parisien d'adoption que vous
êtes vous préparer habilement votre
retour sur vos terres natales et vous
savez que le breton peut être rancunier
donc pour le flatter rien de mieux que
de faire la promotion d'un plat breton
comme le marbre non j'ai rien dit disons
plutôt le quitta farce c'est l'occasion
de faire de la pub pour votre terroir
pour vos traditions avec le phare et le
sac on verra ça en détail tout à l'heure
et puis aussi pour cette langue
régionale si riche qui cafards sont pas
le prononcer au moins une dizaine de
fois une quinzaine de fois dans cette
émission durant l'émission le contrat
est donc plus que rempli voilà donc une
opération retour au pays rondement menée
mais j'espère quand même françois de
rugy que tout ça n'est pas qu'une
opération de com et que vous adorez
sincèrement le kick arfa c'est ce que je
prononce bien le mot et moi aussi je ne
suis pas bretonnants au sens je ne parle
pas le breton et d'ailleurs c'est un peu
réducteur ce que vous avez dit puisque
moi je suis né à nantes et j'ai toujours
habité non
moi je considère culturellement
historiquement que la loire atlantique
et en bretagne mais surtout ce plat est
plutôt issus du finistère brûlé
m'arranger pour mac re voila de la
bretagne mais j'ai des origines dans le
finistère par mon père qui lui est né à
landerneau avant j'allais voir ma
grand-mère à landerneau
voilà et qui a une particularité cette
petite ville est un pont habité et par
ailleurs ma grand mère habitait sur le
pont donc c'était une double
joli pont la schl walla est par ailleurs
je passe mes vacances sur l'île
d'ouessant depuis que je suis tout petit
puisque mon père il y avait acheté une
maison il ya déjà plus de 50 ans et donc
c'est plutôt cela que vous voyez il n'y
a pas grand chose à voir avec ma terre
d'élection d'accord et qui est nantes et
à le gâteau nantais lui en revanche le
dessert
circonscription mais alors le kick à
farce c'est un plat que vous mangez
enfants régulièrement pour des occasions
oui c'est un plat que j'ai découvert
vraiment quand j'étais tout petit par ma
grand mère paternelle donc mais qui elle
pour tout dire n'était pas une grande
cuisinière mais qui a transmis la
recette à ma mère qui elle aimait bien
faire la cuisine et qui elle était
d'origine lorraine dont couleur elle
c'était plutôt un plat d'adoption mais
je crois qu'elle le faisait bien et on
en mangeait régulièrement à nantes ou à
ouessant selon les moments où nous
étions
et d'ailleurs je dois dire que je n'ai
jamais cessé d'en faire moi-même et et
voyez l'émission me donne envie de
retrouver la recette ma mère est décédée
malheureusement mais de retrouver la
recette de ma mère et de le faire moi
même car je pense que c'est faisable je
ne suis pas je n'ai pas la prétention
qui vous met bien où ça vous aimez être
au four doux j'aime bien faire la
cuisine de temps en temps je ne vais pas
dire que je me jette sur les fourneaux à
tout instant et je n'ai pas du tout la
prétention d'être un grand cuisine mais
j'aime bien oui préparer des choses
essayer des choses ou refaire des choses
que j'ai
un plat que vous ne mangez jamais en
famille aujourd'hui ou que vous avez
fait découvrir à vos enfants ont pas mes
enfants je pense que ma fille qui a 18
ans a dû déjà en manger avec ma mère mon
fils qui a 10 ans et moins sûr mais ceci
dit oui c'est vraiment un plat familial
je crois que je n'en ai quasiment jamais
mangé au restaurant puis sa hausse est
assez difficile d'en trouver moi je ne
verrais se dorant même en bretagne
oui parce que je pense aussi il faut le
dire c'est là que ça rejoint toujours
aussi un petit peu là l'histoire de
notre pays et c'est que je me demande si
ce n'est pas un plat qu'on cachait par
un peu à une période finalement c'est
plat comme dans d'autres régions qui
étaient des plat du pauvre ou en tout
cas qui étaient considérés comme
déplacés rustique et bien dans les
restaurants on n'aurait pas eu l'idée de
le mettre à la carte c'est revenu je
pense depuis quelques années parce qu on
re découvre entre la potée ici le
pot-au-feu finalement c'est une variante
un peu du pot-au-feu etc te ment c'est
une variante bretonne du poteau où
goûter le pour nous dire cela
commerciaux les plus riches
ceux qui caf ars vient effectivement du
pays du léon il vient d'à côté du
conquet qui est le port qui emmène
justement vers l'île d'ouessant j'ai été
la semaine dernière et donc voilà j'en
ai rapporté exprès pour vous on va le
déguster ensemble en attendant vous nous
c'est vous qui allez nous raconter
l'histoire des tic afin que bon alors on
prononce kikar farce si on ne veut pas
être ridicule du côté de rennes ou de
perros guirec et la traduction littérale
d'après ce que j'ai compris et viande et
fars voilà ce que ça veut dire à
l'origine vous l'avez 17 à plat du
pauvre a composé de là on le voit bien
dans la rue dans la recette que nous a
apporté et brigitte de quelques légumes
carottes et choux ils sont bien là et de
phares noirs ou blancs et c'est là que
ça se complique c'est là où le nom
breton ne comprends pas de quoi il
s'agit avec le temps d'autres légumes et
morceaux de viande ont été ajoutées
comme le jarret de porc leboeuf des
saucisses aussi et tout ça mijote au
moins quatre heures alors la touche
bretonne se sont bien sûr ces fameux
fard noir et blanc voilà le fard noir le
phare blanc françois de rugy ne savais
même pas que ça existait mais
visiblement ça existe quézako eh bien il
s'agit de deux pattes confectionnés avec
du lait des oeufs du bar et de la farine
de froment pour le blanc et du sarrasin
pour le noir les mêmes avec du saindoux
a une origine c'était avec du maine ma
mère allait toujours chercher du
saindoux ce qui de nos jours devient
difficile à trouver d'ailleurs quelques
boucheries vous
quand même bien donc tous à sindou lait
beurre farine c'est dans le sac alors un
sac en tissu enfin dans un sac en tissu
pouvait même décor et oui et parfois ils
sont plutôt rond même d'ailleurs voilà
donc tous à enlever dans le sac et on le
fait cuire le gâteau reste j'ai compris
dans le bouillon d'algues il est cuit
dans le bouillon et ensuite on les
miettes et ça donne ça voilà donc on a
ces deux sacs l'a donc pour le phare
blanc et pour le farm va donner on les
plonge dans la marmite dans le bouillon
et on fait cuire à ce moment là ce qu'on
dit farce mais en fait c'est du phare en
fait c'est dans la farine de blé noir
qu'on trouve là et on doit l'émietter
c'est ça c'est ça les mines étaient où
le couper en tranches moi je les ai
souvent vu couper en tranches à la rbi
couper en tranches alors on peut aller
même jusqu'à le faire un peu de dorer à
la poêle est réellement si on veut avec
du beurre oui c'est d'ailleurs est
revenu alors à griller dans la potion
dit que ça s'appelle le phare bruges noc
voilà et en bon d'où le mot bruges une
haie pour émietter en fait le phare
dessus qui est un des bretonnismes
mais il vous plaît ou pas est ce qu'il
est et ce qu'il a un peu le goût de
votre enfance je ne resterai pas dire le
le goût de celui de votre maman mais oui
cela vous rappelle les ultras bon c'est
une bonne adresse donc et c'est très
très réussie alors c'est vrai que celui
que faisait ma maman était plus gris il
était je pense peut-être plus chargées
en blé noir à d'accord est vraiment à
elle elle le faisait plutôt en tranches
mais c'est le même goût c'est qu'elle
était sa touche lorraine elle n'a pas
non je crois qu'elle ne mettait aucune
touche l'aurait-elle chercheurs pas
mélanger avec la choucroute ou avec
d'autres recettes de l'est non s'est
elle suivait strictement la cette
bretonne mais qui a des variantes comme
vous l'avait bien dit parce qu'au fil du
temps il a pu être soit accommoder
enrichi en fait exactement comme ça où
un moment donné je pense quasiment
abandonné 1 c'est à dire qu'on ne le
trouvais plus sur les tables et je pense
que des bretons qui recevait des invités
n'allait pas spontanément vers ce plat
et aurait plutôt cherché à présenter les
fruits de mer on le mange quand même
assez régulièrement en tout cas dans le
pays du léon vous disiez rennes tout à
l'heure mais c'est vraiment le pays du
lait monde c'est à dire entre morlaix et
brest quoi en fait vraiment partie la
pointe nord de la bretagne c'est
vraiment de là qu il était originaire et
régulièrement dans cette partie en tout
cas ça c'est très bon parce qu'on a
l'impression de manger une angine
crédible et noir donc on le met alors
comment on fait on met là dedans oui on
le nom le mais par dessus le mélange est
houleux où le danger est comme ça voilà
je pense que l'actuel président de
l'assemblée nationale ça nous fait un
petit point commun doit connaître ce
placard il est élu du finistère et il a
dans sa circonscription d'ailleurs l'île
d'ouessant nous avons cela en commun
donc sans aucun doute il doit connaître
sa classe ce plat là on n'a pas encore
reçu richard ferrand à lui lancé une
adresse et un bon moment c'est délicat
parce c'est très bon et je milite pour
que les restaurants bretons au lieu nous
sépare toujours les sempiternelles qui
se remettent et nous fera découvrir aux
parisiens à la france sa place mais
peut-être d'autres spécialités bretonnes
il y en a d'autres que vous affectionnez
aussi alors il ya une spécialité oui
centimes voilà là on a été assez c'est
le concentré de bretagne et là c'est
autre chose encore mais c'est pareil
c'est une recette qui a été redécouverte
seulement il ya quelques années et qu'on
appelle alors il ya deux parties une
partie on va dire vraiment le plat de
résistance qui est le ragoût dans les
mottes et donc c'est pareil au départ
c'était une recette qui avait été fait
pour permettre aux hommes et aux femmes
de partir travailler toute la journée
dans les champs et donc on faisait cuire
l'équivalent en arabe où nous en sommes
à mijoter dans une casserole en fonte
entouré de mode qui se consumait très
très lentement de moss 1 c'est un espace
où il n'ya pas de combustible il ya très
peu d'arbres donc on n'a pas de bois et
donc ses modes mais en fait c'est la
surface du sol où il ya un peu d'herbe
un peu de bruit hier et un peu de terre
et tout ça se consume très très
lentement et permet d'avoir quelque
chose de très mystérieux voire presque à
la fin un peu grillé sur le dessus et
donc c'est quelque chose qui est très
bon mais c'est pareil vous n'en
trouverez pas dans les restaurants et
pour cause parce que là et refaire un
four avec des menottes en plein paris
c'est un peu compliqué mais sur l'île
d'ouessant aujourd'hui on en retrouve et
il y a le phare dans les modes donc qui
est une version un peu particulière
parce que c'est un phare avec de la
pomme de terre râpées et du lard donc
c'est un peu entre le salé ah oui un
gâteau est cuit de la même façon les
crêpes bretonnes fois les crêpes vous en
vous en mangez régulièrement vous
enferme j'en ai encore fait le week end
dernier mes enfants alors cuisine et
vous savez j'ai moins convaincu mes
enfants pour l'instant du vol et noir
femmes en sari et moi je fais les deux
j'aime beaucoup les ce que nous à nantes
et à rennes nous appelons les galettes
de blé noir alors que dans le finistère
la bretagne plus à l'ouest on ne parle
pas de galettes crêpes et rira rendra
d'ailleurs à nantes on ne met que du blé
noir alors que souvent dans le finistère
en mélange le blé noir avec de la grêle
se tiennent mieux quand on mélange donc
c'est dur de faire des vrais crêpes au
sarrasin en fait un bâton avant à la
veille donc fait comment on ne peut le
faire tout de suite avec des oeufs c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus simple un mail à le
blé noir vous mélangez la farine de blé
noir moi je mets quand même un neuf ça
permet de lire un petit peu un peu de
sel et de l'eau il ne faut surtout pas
mettre de l'est car si on met du lait ça
va accrocher et les galettes vont être
raté mais par ailleurs si vous voyez
quand même le niveau de revenu et c'est
très pauvre il n'y a pas besoin de 2,2
alors une petite anecdote mais vous
dites que vous mangez beaucoup de blé
noir vous pouvez manger aussi des crêpes
sucrées avec du blé noir c'est excellent
jeu vous propose des chocolats blé noir
où j'adorais miel
est aujourd'hui à même des gens qui ont
préparé des galettes de blé noir un peu
séché comme des chips d'apéritif alain
houde et enroulé on peut aussi faire des
enroulée et des crêpes roulées les
couper en petits morceaux pour
l'apéritif vous faites référence est une
enseigne parisienne maintenant qu'il
fait ça n'ont même pas non mais je vois
dans les rangs dans les commerces
aujourd'hui
non je pense dans toute la bretagne on
va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollables françois de rugy c'est le
quiz
alors
question assez compliqué
quel est le plat salé préféré des
bretons en 2021 alors pour poser cette
question je m'appuie sur le site
marmiton bien connue de tous les
cuisiniers qui a fait un sondage région
par région sur les recettes les plus
consultées donc si elles sont les plus
consultés on peut préjuger quels sont
les plus exécutées alors à magret de
canard b courgettes farcies
le rougail saucisses et pardon et des
cannellonis à la viande quel est donc le
plat salé préféré des bretons selon le
site marmiton sachant qu'il n'ya aucun
plat bretons parmi ankara précision mais
on s'en doute que les bretons
connaissons bien leur place oui j'ai à
faire c'est d'ailleurs donc peut-être
que l'exotisme peut être une piste irait
peut-être le rougail saucisses et ben
bravo c'est ça qu'on aime bien quand
même ses soutiens bien au corps samedi
non mais sérieux beaucoup de bretons qui
sont aller coloniser l'île de la réunion
au moment des colons et les marins les
marins bretons ont parcouru le monde
pour leur travail c'est sous ce nom que
celle qui vient en fait de madagascar
mais l'essai à l'île de la réunion
effectivement qu'on en mange aujourd'hui
deuxième quiz alors un des trésors de
votre terroir nantais le canard nantais
ou canard de challans seriez vous nous
dire si ces affirmations sont vraies ou
fausses ah il est issu du croisement des
colverts du poitou et des canards
migrateurs venu de hollande vrai ou faux
oh je dirais que c'est peut-être vrai
oui c'est vrai c'est exact je savais
qu'il y avait une petite d'ailleurs
colonie hollandaise à nantes et nous
avons un nom d'ailleurs la place de la
petite hollande en plein centre ville de
nantes et qui est s'appelle ainsi car
c'était tout simplement parce qu'il y
avait assez tendre l'incertain de
commerçant hollandais qui au xviiie
siècle était venu à nantes puisque
nantes était un port important et ce
sont sourds sont douteux qui ont amené
leurs camardes pour faire ces
croisements fort possible alors b il a
obtenu le label rouge en 2000 est-ce que
c'est vrai ou est-ce que c'est faux oh
c'est sans doute vrai alors je pense que
c'est vrai qu'il a le label peut-être
pas en 2009 à lui bien là bien avant
peut-être en
1906 et il vit dans les marais et
l'estuaire de la loire vrai ou faux
alors à l'origine il ya beaucoup de
canard ça c'est qu'un doute dans
l'estuaire de la loire après les canards
d'élevage
ils ne sont pas spécialement située sur
l'estuaire parce que challes en
l'occurrence et en vendée c'est plutôt
l'intérieur des terres voilà là c'était
vrai à
l'origine oui ces canards au début
vivait dans sa reste d'ailleurs un
territoire de chasse avec parfois les
conflits qui lie à un retour de la
chasse le fameux canard du canard au son
canard au sang la tour d'argent est
rarement un canard nantes est vrai au
fond je pense que c'est vrai je pense
que c'est un canard d'ailleurs mais je
n'y suis jamais allé je ne peux pas
juger
alors c'est non c'est toujours un canard
m'embête toujours à kazan selon une
tradition maison modeste à nantes à la
fois plus plus sérieusement vous savez
que malheureusement la région a été très
touché par la grippe aviaire et donc la
production a été vraiment très fortement
atteinte particulièrement dans la région
donc de chalon on a détruit
effectivement tous les horizons a battu
très grande partie se chiffrent en
milliers de bêtes voilà et c'est surtout
il faut imaginer que c'est toute une
production qui est perdue puisque le
temps de reconstituer et bien il
s'écoule plusieurs mois sans avoir
aucune production c'est très dur à vivre
pour les éleveurs et ça a un impact
évidemment sur l'approvisionnement aussi
puisque aujourd'hui vous ne trouvez plus
un certains nombres de mai à partir de
canard dans les restaurants alors là on
parle viande mais vous êtes quand même
en bordure de la mer
est ce que oui est ce que vous aimez le
poisson est ce que vous mangez un peu de
oui alors dit de la merde eu l'occasion
de le dire dans d'autres circonstances
qui était moins agréable mais moi je
suis un pécheur je ne suis pas un
chasseur mais je suis un pécheur et
alors je n'ai pas beaucoup de temps
malheureusement pour aller à la pêche et
je pratique plutôt la pêche dans le
finistère à ouessant est pas et pas du
tout dans la région nantaise et
j'ai toujours aimé le poisson et je n'ai
jamais aimé les fruits de mer c'est
ainsi alors on n'a pas cru quand j'ai
dit ça mais tous les gens qui me
connaissent notamment le maire
d'ouessant avait dit un jour en
accueillant barbara pompili qui à
l'époque est secrétaire d'état la
biodiversité en présence du député
richard ferrand qui n'était pas encore
prise en assemblée bien sûr eh bien il
avait dit à mais nous aurions pu
demander à françois de nous fournir des
homards pour le déjeuner car il empêche
et ils en mangent jamais j'aurais dû
enregistrer cette petite séquence car
elles auraient pu être utiles à d'autres
j'ai même cru comprendre que c'était une
allergie nous c'est une formule que l'on
dit quand vous savez on n'aime pas trop
quelque chose on y je suis allergique
mon grand père d'ailleurs maternelle
était lui allergies ou presque violent
fruits de mer et au gibier d'ailleurs
mais en tout cas moi je ne mange pas de
fruits de mer mais j'aime bien pêcher
donc observer la pêche aux crustacés
c'est des casiers voulait poser le soir
avoue rené le lendemain voilà et donc au
casier il y en a deux c'est
réglementaire on a droit à deux casiers
par bateau et il la plupart du temps ils
sont vides d'ailleurs et puis parfois
vous avez la chance d'avoir des
crustacés de gens même parfois les
choses plus étonnantes un petit poule
pour un petit voilà ça fait toujours le
bonheur des enfants d'ailleurs d'aller
relever les casiers parce qu'on voit
s'il ya quelque chose ou pas et on a
parfois des surprises mais voilà moi
j'aime beaucoup le poisson en revanche
et je suis toujours étonné hier que les
gens confondent considère que fruits de
mer ça couvre ça englobe les poissons
alors que la chair du poisson l'un n'a
vraiment pas du tout le même goût que la
chair des autres fruits de mer je n'aime
pas non plus les moules les huîtres qui
sont aussi très différent c'est pour un
bretons c'est un peu dommage voilà une
époque à ouessant d'ailleurs il y avait
des cultures de mou y en a beaucoup dans
la région aux lois sud de la loire
atlantique vendée il ya beaucoup de
huîtres bien sûr partout en bretagne
mais aussi en normandie mais aussi plus
au sud et en france et donc on a la
chance en france d'être une région
productrice j'ai eu à le voir aussi
quand j'étais ministre parce que ce sont
des équipes très fragile la culture
d'huîtres et de moules ce sont des
témoins de la qualité de l'eau et donc
dès que l'eau en général c'est l'eau
douce polluer qui arrive dans l'eau de
mer sur les littoraux ou dans les étangs
comme les tantôt par exemple dans le sud
de la france à ce moment là on est
obligé même teinté tir totalement la
vente des moules et des huîtres et donc
ça peu la cata ce n'est jamais une
huître jamais alors je suis souvent je
déçois espace où l'on aime bien offrir
quand on arrive dans un pays huîtres de
production en plus on considère qu'on
peut en manger comme ça à l'apéritif à
nantes sur les marchés de nantes die
toujours les dégustations d'huîtres et
muscadet droit de faire des vins à la
télévision et donc c'est quelque chose
qui est très courant mais moi je
en revanche vous êtes écolo vous mangez
bio local vous faites attention quand
vous achetez vos produits au marché oui
alors mes parents m'avaient transmis
cela à l'époque c'était assez rare moi
je suis né dans les années 70 donc
c'était vraiment les pionniers à
l'époque de l'agriculture biologique des
produits - transformer des céréales qui
noie par exemple qui maintenant est très
connu ma mère a commencé à nous en
servir à l'époque où personne n'en
parlait c'était les magasins plutôt
savez tous ses magasins de commerce
équitable tenue au départ par des
bénévoles et c'est baba cool à l'époque
mon jeu du qui doit un peu dire voilà
que c'était post 68 mais pour autant moi
je je je pense qu'il ne faut pas non
plus stigmatiser
l'agriculture conventionnelle
là c'est plus par mon activité politique
que j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter
énormément d'exploitation
quand j'étais ministre en tant que
député quand j'étais candidat aux
régionales l'année dernière et il ya en
france une qualité
de production y compris donc dans
l'agriculture conventionnelle qu'il faut
défendre et qu'il faut promouvoir parce
que sinon on a l'impression que c'est la
malbouffe que ces choses là et en
réduisant les intrants les pesticides
l'impact négatif sur l'environnement il
existe aussi et il peut aussi due à
l'agriculture et donc il faut aussi
indécente et évidemment ils travailler
mais oui mais par exemple il faut pas
dire ah si vous mangez une carotte issus
de l'agriculture conventionnelle dont on
a beaucoup de matches et tout autour de
nantes ou de la salade de la mâche 80 %
de la masse consommé en france est
produite à côté de nantes ah bah vous
allez avoir un cancer plus tard parce
que il ya des pc ça ce serait vraiment
absurde donc il faut garder le sens de
la mesure je sais que de nos jours les
médias la politique c'est plus tellement
le sens de la mesure et puisqu'on est un
haletant de s'exprimer autour d'une
table je pense qu'on peut dire ces
choses là tranquillement et rassurer
aussi les français y compris dans le
monde on est une des agricultures les
plus exigeante sur la qualité
reconnaissant qu'en bretagne vous avez
un fléau c'est l'élevage intensif de
porcs qui causent des dommages avec les
os et les agneaux verts qui sont payés
dus aux nitrates qui eux mêmes sont sûrs
au fait qu'a fait beau d'épandage mais
ça il faut pas non plus dire à l'élevage
industriel un fléau parce que la
production de porcs ou de poulet en
grande quantité ça correspond à une
demande de consommation aujourd'hui on
parle beaucoup du pouvoir d'achat les
français n'ont pas envie de voir le prix
du porc le prix du poulet doublé + nord
souvent quand même canton moi je connais
bien justement l'agriculture biologique
quand on passe dans le bio on a quand
même souvent une augmentation de prix
kelkoo importante élevé ce qui est
logique puisque qui passait ses vacances
voilà le rendement est plus faible et le
temps parler des canards un poulet si un
poulet bio en effet il vit plus
longtemps ça peut-être trois mois quatre
mois quand un poulet conventionnés va
peut-être est juste juste trente jours
donc c'est sûr que ça coûte plus cher
donc là aussi gardant le sens de nageurs
parce que je voudrais mettre conscient
qu'en france on importe 40% de la
volaille qu'on consomme et cette
volaille qu'on importe émincé de
volaille bio c'est plutôt de la volaille
a du brésil rottiers vraiment très bas
de gamme alors en france vous savez le
repas occupent une large place est
particulièrement en politique c'est
souvent à table que se nouent les deals
politique que se fait la petite et la
grande histoire c'est la brève de
comptoir
alors françois de rugy vous a demandé de
réfléchir à une anecdote autour d'un
repas pourquoi pas en politique est-ce
qu'il y en a une qui vous est revenue à
l'esprit alors d'abord il ya un peu un
mythe que vous avez vous-même d'ailleurs
activé en disant qu en politique puis se
règlerait autour de repas non je crois
qu'elle beau la plupart des choses ne
seraient ils pas autour de repas se
règle dans des salles de réunions
souvent plutôt blafarde et où vieillotte
et c'est normal parce qu'on passe tout
son temps au cou soit en réunion sont
visite sur le terrain et vous savez
quand on est en visite sur le terrain en
général malheureusement on n'a pas le
temps de manger là aussi à une époque on
m'a opposé l'image d'une ministre
suédoise en train de manger un sandwich
sur inquiète mais moi j'aurais pu en
faire des dizaines des images comme ça
mais il ya une culture de la table quand
mais il est une culture de l'année est
plutôt une culture d'ailleurs et je
trouve que c'est bien pour valoriser ce
que l'on fait donc un peu d'apparat ce
qui peut d'ailleurs donné l'impression
qu'à chaque fois ce sont les repas
luxueux alors que c'est la tradition de
la table française
quand j'ai reçu mon homologue président
de l'assemblée nationale le bundestag en
allemagne et bien évidemment les
services de l'assemblée ont mis plus que
des petits plats dans les grands ils ont
sorti la vaisselle etc parce que c'est
un homme aux mains de marc sion alors ça
évidemment il y en a des déjeuners ou
des dîners comme cela et des dîners
d'état et on emploie cette expression
dîner d'état donc ça veut tout dire
souvent d'ailleurs nos autres ne sont
moins sensibles j'ai le souvenir du
président chinois bon qui visiblement
avait plutôt envie d'écourter selon
cérémonial français est alors moi j'ai
une petite anecdote je crois qu'il ne
m'en voudra pas de dire cela c'est
l'actuel président du sénat gérard
larcher je pense que avoir noué une
relation avec lui au delà de la
politique et de l'institutionnel quand
j'étais président de l'assemblée
nationale on ne se connaissait pas
auparavant très peu et autour de repas
c'est vrai car c'est un bon vivant
chacun le sait il est un bon coup de
fourchette il aime bien même parfois lui
servir à table des produits de sa chasse
puisque lui et chasseurs au sénat je
l'ait reçue à l'assemblée quand j'étais
présent la zone et il m'a reçu au sénat
mais nous nous sommes vus aussi dans le
cadre privé et nous avons en plus en
commun lui ce n'est pas l'île d'ouessant
c'est l'île de batz aussi dans le
finistère-nord et donc je suis allé chez
lui donc voilà ça c'est vrai que je peux
dire qu'avec lui je crois qu'il ne me
démentira pas une relation a pu se nouer
grâce aux autour de la gastronomie et
autour de plats et de la table c'est se
fait alors on va avancer dans cette
émission a parlé de l'huile de tournesol
qui est devenu un précieux sésame depuis
le début de la guerre en ukraine de la
graine à la bouteille tout le monde se
l'arrachent c'est le dessous des plats
oui force de rhji vous avez dû le
constater vous même si vous faites des
courses dans les supermarchés en
conséquence de la guerre en ukraine plus
une bouteille d'huile de tournesol
disponible en magasin c'est la pénurie
et complète qui fait le malheur des
cuisiniers qui aiment cuisiner à la
grande friture et qui fait aussi le
bonheur de quelques agriculteurs qui
profitent de l'aubaine pour planter du
tournesol c'est un reportage de léo se
et d'antoine coûta
des frites tout juste sortis de leur
bain d'huile une huile de tournesol
désormais bien difficile à trouver un
prix raisonnable et la gérante il fait
très attention
avant je le faisais partie avec lui de
20 litres consommés chaque semaine
la restauratrice a fait quelques
réserves je vais vous montrer ou stack
m'ennuie donc c'est juste ici
nous et 180 litres qui sont actuellement
ressort de quoi tenir six à sept
semaines après elle paiera le prix fort
en 2021 on était à une trentaine d'euros
pour les 25 litres en janvier on a subi
une première augmentation où j'étais
monté à 52 euros je trouvais ça déjà
c'est cher ensuite encore une
augmentation à 110 euros en français ça
s'arrête pas d'augmenter vent ça s'ouvre
demain je vais vous dire que les 25
des prix en hausse une aubaine pour
certains comme cet agriculteur qui
misent sur cette grande fleur jaune ce
tournesol il a été semé fin mars le
tournesol est pas la culture la plus
adaptée à notre territoire donc là c'est
vraiment le prix qui comme nous a
motivés à faire du tout seul d'habitude
peu rentables ici la perspective d'un
cours du tournesol élevé avec le conflit
ukrainien on a décidé plus d'un cette
parcelle là par exemple qui en tournesol
et puis c'est là un petit peu plus loin
aussi au gaz a également fait du
tournesol pour la récolte il faudra
attendre la fin de l'été alors pour
éviter toute rupture d'approvisionnement
industriels et grand consommateur de
l'huile se tournent désormais vers celle
de colza cette coopérative installée
dans la vienne peut en témoigner
depuis le début du conflit ukraine rossi
et l'usiné tourne à plein régime compte
tenu de la demande en huile notamment
sur l'huile alimentaire
les graines de colza arriver c'est ce
chemin avant d'arriver dans la presse
et au bout de la chaîne on obtient huile
de colza raffinés c'est ça voilà que
tout le monde s'arrache est utilisé en
industrie assailli de demandes de
restaurateurs ou de collectivités lusine
a même dû s'adapter
on a train de charger un camion de 30
mille litres c'est le conditionnement
habituels qu'on avait depuis le début de
l' usine et plus récemment on est passé
sur du conditionnement un petit peu plus
petit face à la demande des clients ont
fait des cuves mille litres et on est en
train de préparer également des bidons
de 5 litres pour dépanner les
restaurateurs du pointe
juste qu'il soit dans les magasins on
n'en voit plus d'ailleurs c'est vide
donc comme on sait on peut appeler ça de
l'ordre l'huile de colza a
progressivement atteint le prix de celle
de tournesol c'est la règle sur ce
marché des huiles mondialisé et
interdépendants
alors françois de rugy que vous inspire
cette ruée cette razzia sur les étals
celle angoisses du hot en guerre qui
fait ça c'est sans doute qu'on a un peu
oublié que l'approvisionnement en
alimentation c'est pas quelque chose qui
tombe du ciel ce n'est pas quelque chose
qui est fascine c'est pas quelque chose
qui est advitam eternam abondant et bon
marché on s'est habitué en france et en
mieux à une alimentation pour marcher à
au fait que sauf quand il est le co vide
au début et que tout le monde s'est rué
pour acheter des pâtes et du riz dans
les supermarchés il n'y a pas de pénurie
dans les supermarchés ou dans les petits
commerces en france sur l'alimentation
mais derrière cela derrière cet acte
banal il y à toute une machinerie de
production et je dois dire que ce qui
m'inquiète un peu depuis quelques années
en france on ne parle plus beaucoup de
la production on parle de est-ce que ça
va polluer on parle de est-ce que ça va
être bien consommée est ce de la
sécurité sanitaire tout ça est normal
mais il faut quand même être conscient
qu'il faut produire regardez dans cette
campagne électorale mais ce qu'il
faudrait prendre part de la production
qu'il faudrait produire le tout parce
qu'il faudrait énormément de tournesol
nous oui porte beaucoup pas être
forcément autosuffisant dans tous les
domaines mais quand même la france est
un pays qui a une chance géographique je
suis un fils de professeurs d'histoire
géographie est bien c'est d'avoir une
très grande diversité de territoires
nous sommes le seul pays d'europe qui a
à la fois un petit bout de la mer du
nord et une façade méditerranéenne donc
on peut à la fois produire de l'huile
d'olive produire de l'huile de tournesol
ou de colza dans les grandes plaines de
la beauce par exemple dans le grand
bassin parisien comme on peut produire
du comté un jour à produire de tout en
quantité suffisante pour nourrir c'est
non seulement ce qu'il faut viser bien
sûr et c'est possible et c'est possible
mais bien évidemment avait il pas rage
industriel tous les types d'agriculture
et aussi avoir en europe parce que nous
avons une politique agricole commune qui
est quand même une réussite européenne
qui sont seize discuté il ya une réforme
d'ailleurs qui est actuellement en cours
de définition il va pas falloir se
tromper parce que dans cette réforme qui
était prévu appelé en anglais form to
fork c'est à dire de la ferme à la
fourchette et bien il était prévu de
baisser la production en disant ben en
fait où on est plutôt guetté par la
traduction versée à cause de la guerre
et vous imaginez c'est à dire que c'est
un rappel un peu brutal al-aryane hiver
nous a quand même appris qu'il fallait
retrouver de la souveraineté également
dans la demande et moi je vais même plus
loin il faut absolument que nous ayons
une agriculture d'exportation
c'est vrai pour la france nous avons des
bons produits qui peuvent s'exporter qui
ont une bonne image partout en europe et
dans le monde et nous avons aussi des
productions de base comme les céréales
par exemple où nous pouvons non
seulement exporté en europe mais par
exemple chez nos voisins proches du
maghreb en main le maghreb ne peut le
veulent pourquoi le voudraient importer
de la nourriture française parce que le
maghreb par exemple et où la population
augmente l'egypte dépend à 80% des
importations du blé ukrainien ou russe
russe ou ruhr se nourrir or les pays en
plus du maghreb mange plus de blé et de
ses différents dérivés que nous donc ces
pays là ne pourront jamais produire
c'est une question géographique on ne
peut pas produire dans les pays du
maghreb beaucoup de céréales ces sont
des pays sec aride où on peut faire
d'autres productions mais très peu de
céréales et donc c'est absolument
nécessaire que la france au sein de
l'union européenne défende cette idée
qu'il faut de la production et notamment
la l'exemple de l'huile d'olive en est
un et enfin de l'huile pardon de total
en est un exemple avant avant cette
crise y avait des producteurs d'huile de
tournesol en france mais il avait du mal
à écouler leurs productions aux
questions c'est aujourd'hui qu'il
redécouvre à cause de cette pénurie
d'ailleurs on voit bien un reportage et
moi je lisais encore ce matin à papier
des producteurs qui ont monté une petite
coopérative depuis la guerre et ils font
un carton il n'arrête pas de vendre les
demandes sont conséquentes et maintenant
ils font un peu de bénéfices mais avant
il ne gagne pas d'argent avec leur huile
oui et regardez nous sommes à
l'assemblée nationale le débat que nous
avons eu à l'assemblée nationale il ya
deux ans et demi un lieu deux ans et
demi sur les néonicotinoïdes ce
traitement permet de lutter contre
certains parasites notamment
celui qui touche les betteraves la
filière betteravière en france elle y
fait bon certes pour qu'on puisse manger
de temps en temps de la mettra mais elle
est surtout faite pour produire du sucre
elle est liée à la filière sucrière
depuis des années on ferme un certain
nombre d' usine de transformation de
mettra en sucre les surfaces qui sont
minorés tram se réduisent si on ne
réalisait pas ce produit le temps de
trouver d'autres solutions c est l
ensemble de la production betteravière
qu'ils allaient étaient toutes les
flèches qui disparaît alors certains
vous disait y compris au nom de
l'écologie ce qui est un comble mais
c'est pas grave on peut importer sans
problème de la betterave de pologne mais
que sa venue en paix je peux dire que
cela de la canne à sucre et ou du sucre
déjà a fait du brésil d'amérique du sud
vous croyez qu'il est fait alors avec
sans produits chimiques taxe carbone et
le règne du produit chimique absolue bon
et bien et en plus ça d'un point de vue
de l'impact carbone de l'alimentation
c'est aberrant eh bien il faut reprendre
conscience de la nécessité de produire
et d'ailleurs regardons ce qu'ont fait
les russes sous la houlette de vladimir
poutine avant de lancer cette guerre en
ukraine eux ils ont pensé qu'il fallait
qu'il relance la production ils avaient
beaucoup perdu après la chute de l'union
soviétique sur un certain nombre de
productions alimentaires de base et
qu'il soit exportateurs et bien il faut
que l'on reprenne conscience de cette
nécessité en france et en europe et la
france est quand même un des coeurs
agricole de l'europe moi je ne suis pas
fils ou petit fils d'agriculteurs mais
j'ai vraiment cette passion c'est une
faire partager à la fois aux françaises
et aux français notamment aux urbains
moi je suis un élu d'une circonscription
urbaine je suis moi-même un urbain mais
partageons cette prise de conscience
qu'il faut d'abord et avant tout
produire si on veut pouvoir avoir de
bonnes choses dans notre nom nos
assiettes si on ne veut pas avoir même
sans parler de pénurie des augmentations
de prix trop fortes sur un certain
nombre de produits il faut que nous
fassions petit billet à produire des
exploitations paysannes parce que c'est
ce qu'on entend aujourd'hui les grosses
exploitations qui sont à la fois source
de effectivement d'utilisation de
pesticides qui polluent qui abîment
l'environnement est-ce qu'il faut
multiplier ces petites exploitations on
a le droit de parler un petit peu de la
campagne pour les législatives moi je ne
suis pas candidat donc si je ne le dis
pas pour moi mais voyez bien qu'il ya
des courants politiques qui disent cela
ah mais il faut remplacer remplacer les
grandes exploitations agricoles par des
petites et puis on va créer des emplois
etc mais en faisant baisser les
rendements alors déjà premières choses
il ya une question physique
si vous faites deux fois moins de blé à
l'hectare le bio c'est deux fois moins
après ça veut dire qu'il faudra deux
fois plus d'hectares cultivés pour avoir
la même produit qui vous en dira
ministre de la transition écologique
vous dit qu il faut pas faire de bio je
dis attention à ne pas vouloir tout
faire de la même façon moi je pense
qu'en france ni les à la place pour tous
les types de cultures vous avez la place
pour la micro ferme urbaine qui ne
nourrira jamais tous les habitants de la
ville 1 il faut aussi arrêter avec cette
illusion c'est la campagne qui nourrit
la ville sinon on n'y arrive pas mais
pourquoi pas les micros ferme urbaine
souvent très artificielle parce que les
fermes sur les toits c'est pas du sol
naturel il ya beaucoup de produits
chimiques d'ailleurs souvent et c'est de
l'irrigation à 100% c'est pas juste la
plus tôt mais avec des petites
gouttelettes avec coco souvent à leur
maman de reconnaissons la corderie et
donc pourquoi pas de l'agriculture on va
dire au bio de l'agriculture paysanne
traditionnelle qui n'est pas forcément
bio vous savez les fermes par exemple
syndicat confédération paysanne qui
défend l'agriculture familiale paysanne
elle défend une surface aujourd'hui
qu'elle combattait ya 30 ans parce
qu'elle trouvait que c'était trop grand
mais aujourd'hui on a de fait un peu
grandi la plupart des gens qui ont des
grandes exploitations en fait ils sont
associés ils sont plusieurs par un
agriculteur qui a 500 hectares de
céréales dans la base c'est un gaec avec
des associés et ainsi de suite et ça oui
il faut défendre cela tout en ayant une
plus grande utilisation de la
technologie ne faut surtout pas refuser
le progrès technologique en agriculture
quand j'entends parfois des gens qui
disent hors revenons aux pratiques
culturales d'antan mais lesquels saïd
dans les années 50 60 70 en france on
utilise à des produits chimiques était
bien pire que ce qu'on est dit
aujourd'hui qu'on était interdite
heureusement le lindane par exemple une
petite musique il faut revenir à la
terre avec ses bras enlever les machines
auront bien le rio c'est aussi ça c'est
plus travailler la terre c'est sûr mais
vous avez une agriculture par exemple de
conservation des sols la plupart des
gens qui n'ont rien qu'est ce que c'est
que cette histoire est bien ça c'est pas
une question de goût c'est une pratique
en effet cultural que des grandes
exploitations peuvent faire mais par
exemple le paradoxe donc faut avoir ça
en tête c'est que si vous interdisez
totalement le glyphosate mais vous ne
pourrez plus faire d'agriculture de
conservation des sols or l'agriculture
de conservation des sols elle joue un
rôle bénéfique pour le climat tout se
tient
pas simplement en effet notre assiette
et le prix de l'huile de tournesol au
supermarché alors on va parler
maintenant la sécheresse qui met en
péril nos cultures alors faut-il contre
et naturellement le réchauffement ou
retenir l'eau de pluie on en parle et on
met les pieds dans le plat
car françois de rugy l'agriculture
représente 50% de la consommation d'eau
en europe mais l'eau vient à manquer le
dérèglement climatique abusivement
appelée réchauffement climatique
provoque en tout cas des sécheresse sans
précédent est rare à cette période de
l'année les agriculteurs tentent de
s'adapter comme ici dans le finistère
grâce à l'agroforesterie
reportage à saint jean du doigt de julie
jeune maître et christian pollet
sur les cultures d'artichaut de ce
producteur l'absence de pluie se fait
cruellement ressentir voilà on voit que
c'est très sec donc on voit les mêmes la
mode de terrain on voit que ya peu
d'humilité mais pas grand chose pas
suffisamment pour la culture de légumes
face au phénomène de sécheresse jean
yves masson a d'ores et déjà aménagé des
retenues d'eau s'adapter et anticiper
les changements climatiques sont les
maîtres mots de l'agriculteur également
éleveur laitier et en ce moment ce sont
surtout ses pâtures asséchées par les
vents qui le contrarie alors il a misé
sur l'agroforesterie
planter des arbres pour protéger des
bourrasques et cela a bien d'autres
avantages de ces arbres là ont la
faculté d'aller en profondeur chercher
de l'eau et
et donc de l'eau mais aussi d'autres des
oligo éléments qu'on a plus en surface
parce qu à force d'exploitation depuis
de nombreuses années et donc dans les
feuilletons dans les feuilles quand
elles tomberont à l'automne apporte
ronces et oligo-éléments que qu'on a
plus en surface depuis cet hiver 350
arbres de toutes sortes kadri désormais
ses 110 hectares de terrain si certains
considèrent la démarche comme un retour
en arrière l'agriculteur il voit une
façon de valoriser ses champs beaucoup
de gens pensent que les ars vont
pénaliser la culture est en fait celle
inverse que obtenir parce que
globalement tous les études qui ont été
réalisées sur l'agroforesterie c'est
entre 15 et 25 % de rendement derme
réalisé par hectare il faudra bien
quelques années avant que les arbres ne
grandissent mais s'engager pour
l'agriculture de demain c'est un pari
que jean yves masson est prêt à prendre
d'autant que le projet est financé par
le département
alors on vient de le voir dans ce sujet
de france 3 bretagne planter des arbres
pour faire de l'ombre c'est la solution
contre la sécheresse est une bonne
solution pour vous l'agroforesterie
c'est comme ça que ça s'appelle est un
quelque chose de très intéressant qu'il
faut développer pour plein de raisons y
compris l'adaptation au réchauffement
climatique mais aussi ça ça permet de
remettre de la biodiversité comme les y
ait en fait c'est redécouvrir un peu
aussi des aires en bordure de champ
après vous n'allez pas pouvoir mettre
des arbres tous les 5 mètres dans un
champ de céréales parce que sinon vous
n'aurez plus de production de céréales
vous allez faire chuter le rendement
donc faux il faut regarder les arbres en
fait mais aussi l'eau ceux ci ont cessé
dans votre jardin vous verrez que dans
un rond tout autour de l'arbre bon ça
pousse quand même beaucoup moins bien et
c'est normal larmes se nourrit n'est pas
compatible avec toutes les cultures non
syphonner les mêmes les haies moi je
suis un grand militant de la
replantation des haies le long des
champs on a malheureusement beaucoup
arraché pendant plusieurs décennies et
c'est clair ça fait perdre quand même du
rendement donc il faut être capable
d'ailleurs d'indemniser en quelque sorte
de subventionner non seulement la
plantation de haies mais tout au long de
tous les ans de dire un agriculteur bon
ben voilà c'est un contrat un vous
planter des haies et vous les entretenir
et c'est le long de vos champs vous
allez perdre un peu donc on va financer
cela est
du coup c'est dans le cadre de la
politique agricole commune de
subventions que ça peut se faire après
il faut être clair pour faire face aux
sécheresses de plus en plus fortes de
plus en plus longues et touchant de plus
en plus de régions en france
c'est-à-dire pas simplement le bassin
méditerranéen et bien il faut avoir une
politique de gestion de l'eau y compris
disons le mot qui est considéré comme un
gros mot par un certain nombre de
militants associatifs voir certains
syndicalistes agricoles le stockage de
l'eau si vous ne faites pas de stockage
de l'eau et les écologistes appellent
les bassines voilà il ya différentes
techniques mais d'ailleurs on peut
discuter de la meilleure façon de le
faire mais ne pas vouloir discuter du
stockage de l'eau c'est vraiment moi je
le dis criminelle pour l'agriculture
dans les années qui ça me prend sur les
nappes phréatiques c'est une forme de
captation d'un bien public alors l'autre
un bien public il faut que ça le reste
c'est à dire que la gestion doit être
partagée mais on a des outils en france
pas croire qu'on ne sait pas faire on a
ce qu'on appelle les agences de bassins
le grand public ne les connais pas mais
c'est des lieux de ces des agences de
l'état mais où sont associés les
collectivités locales où siège aussi des
associations des représentants des
agriculteurs et on peut le décliner à
l'échelle des territoires moi quand
j'étais mis je les fais un endroit et ça
permet d'avoir une gestion claire
transparente partage et de l'eau il ya
la question de qui paye parce que toutes
ces installations coûtent de l'argent
mais si on stocke l'eau en hiver quand
elle est abondante pour la voir en
réserve lorsque les sécheresses
prolongées ce présent que vous avez vu
que la sto mois d'avril on avait besoin
d'eau au mois d'avril sont assez basses
2001 on note on n'ira pas à ce moment là
justement prélevés dans la nappe
phréatique on aura des stockages alors
qu'ils prendront des formes diverses
vous savez que le bassin méditerranéen
c'est à dire les départements des alpes
maritimes du var des bouches du rhône de
l'hérault et ainsi de suite ces
départements où depuis des siècles voire
des millénaires parce que sa date de
l'époque romaine on stocke l'eau et on a
tout un réseau de l'eau de pluie ça
qu'on stocke un oui mais c'est ça le
présent message auprès l'eau de pluie
les parcours mais l'abondance oui mais
on est des amis à lui m'ont permis aussi
de l'eau qui vient des nappes
phréatiques ont les stocks ont étiré on
les stocke oui vous savez c'est non
c'est pire que ça c'est que si on ne
fait rien c'est à dire si on n'a pas de
stockage et bien que va-t-on faire dans
l'urgence quand il ya une sécheresse et
que sinon parce que toute la production
agricole peu dessécher et donc est perdu
et bien à ce moment là on ira pompé dans
les rivières dans les cours d'eau dans
les fleuves ou dans la nappe au moment
c'est au plus bas donc là c'est ce qu'il
faudrait surtout pas faire parce qu'en
effet on aggrave la situation est pas un
problème de politique publique parce que
là en fait en gros si je les écoute
chacun fait ces retenues d'eau donné que
ce soit géré ward ailleurs la puissance
publique récemment public c'est pour ça
que moi quand j'étais ministre par
exemple j'ai refusé des gens qui
voulaient faire dans le late et si vous
les ceux qui ne regardent pas la
vérifier le lac de caussade qui avait
été fait par un coup de force d'une
chambre d'agriculture et d'un syndicat
agricole qui ont été condamné depuis
pour cela nombreuses reprises parce
qu'il disait c'est notre terrain ont
fait ce qu'il veut a bah non c'est l'eau
est un bien commun ce pas parce qu'elle
passe sur mon terrain que je peut
l'arrêter et la garder pour moi sinon à
ce moment là il ya des gens qui vont se
retrouver à sec donc ça c'est absolument
nécessaire que ce soit public moi je
pense d'ailleurs et au jeu faudrait
organiser comme ça a lancé il ya deux
ans pour faire face aux effets du
réchauffement climatique et donc moi je
plaide pour qu'il y ait peut-être
d'ailleurs une espèce de d'établissement
public je ne sais pas qui vraiment
programme parce que ça se fera dans le
temps on n'est heureusement pas le
couteau sous la gorge dès l'été prochain
dans toutes les régions de france mais
on va l'être de plus en plus donc il
faut quand même agir assez rapidement le
grand sud ouest c'est à dire l'aquitaine
et ce qui était la région midi pyrénées
sont en première ligne vont commencer à
vivre ce que vit depuis toujours le
bassin méditerranéen or évidemment on
n'a pas les mêmes cultures par exemple
savez même capacité de culture ça veut
dire qu'on sent que ça veut dire oui
mais c'est une ironie soit là mais
attention il n'y aura jamais ya vous
n'aurez jamais du colza par exemple du
tournesol seront tous du sang o ça
n'existe pas ou du blé sans jouer vous
imaginez le par exemple les légumes
la zone à même là ça les arbres
fruitiers demain d'un certain nombre de
régions si on les arrose pas il ne
produiront pas la vigne la vigne en
france si on n'a pas dans un certain
nombre de régions en a par l'opal
animaux n'y aura pas du côté de rome et
on commence à faire de l'irrigation à
certains endroits parce que sinon elle
dessert vous savez que quand il ya eu le
gel aussi alors ça c'est un peu contre
intuitives comme on dit mais en fait une
des techniques pour protéger la vigne du
elle c'est de l'art osé place en plein
hiver et là il ya des gens qui s'y
opposent mais ça veut dire qu'ils
veulent que bah tant pis on subit mais
là le gel sur la vigne c'est pas une
fois tous les 50 ans ça c'était avant
maintenant avec les effets du
dérèglement climatique tout le bel et
bien ça peut arriver et là c'est arrivé
cinq fois dans les dix dernières années
donc c'est quand même dramatique qui
font que c'est une chance la vigne et
les afriques et donc il faut absolument
qu'on ait cette politique partout sur le
territoire évidemment c'est un peu plus
aigus quand on est un peu plus au sud
mais on voit aujourd'hui des régions
comme le loiret dans le centre de la
france ou chez nous dans l'ouest qui
sont de plus en plus touchés par ces
effets du réchauffement climatique allez
on va passer au dessert à présent et
c'est le péché mignon
alors le péché mignon c'est le temps du
sucre et toujours avec un gâteau nantais
françois de rugy un dessert culte
entourée de légendes urbaines on dit que
l'histoire de ce gâteau aux amandes
seraient liées au commerce qui s'est
développée à partir du xviie siècle au
départ de nantes vers les antilles et
l'afrique avec des importations de rome
et de sucre de canne qui aurait donc
inspiré en 1820 un boulanger nantais on
dit aussi que les marins emporté avec
eux des biscuits qui sont cuits deux
fois comme le dit biscuits mais en
raison du scorbut cette maladie qui
abîment les dents en mer et bien ils
étaient obligés de les imbiber de rome
pour pouvoir les déguster sans dents
alors je ne sais pas si c'est les gens
sont
alors c'est votre le gâteau de votre
enfance où c'est un gâteau des comment
le mange le gâteau dans ted à quelle
occasion on peut le manger en dessert
comme on peut le manger de salon de thé
par exemple je vais faire de la
publicité pour une institution danthez
qui s'appelle la cigale qui était
autrefois la brasserie du théâtre face
au théâtre graslin sur la place graslin
la place du théâtre à nantes et qui en
proposent depuis toujours justement avec
un café voilà alors il faut même être
aller un peu plus loin que ce que vous
avez dit c'est sûr que c'est un gâteau
aussi qui
reflète une part de l'histoire de nantes
qui n'est pas une histoire toute belle à
l'histoire n'est jamais tout belle donc
c'est le commerce triangulaire et le
commerce triangulaire c'était aussi l'
esclavage
c'était le commerce des esclaves des
bateaux partaient de nantes mais aussi
de borderouge et aussi d'angleterre pour
aller vers les côtes africaines
acheter des esclaves voilà c'était
malheureusement ce que l'on faisait à
une époque ensuite les revendre aux
antilles ou aux amériques et là on
revenait avec l'europe avec du sucre du
rang du café enfin tous les produits des
amériques donc c'est sûr que certains
pourraient considérer que c'est
politiquement incorrect mais évidemment
il s'agit pas à travers qu'il yad'autres
faire la promotion du commerce
triangulaire mais il faut rappeler cette
histoire qui est toujours complexe et
que l'on peut retrouver jusque dans un
plat évidemment aujourd'hui on peut
manger du gâteau nanterre toute
tranquillité il n'y a aucun commerce
triangulaire dire ça mais je préfère le
dire parce que sinon on pourrait en noir
ont fait semblant enfin en effet misé un
petit peu l'histoire d'une ville comme
nantes nantes d'ailleurs regarde en face
cette histoire il ya un mémorial à
l'abolition de l'esclavagé qui est sur
le quai de la fosse où elle était
justement les bateaux qui partaient pour
le commerce train alors là il ya un
nappage sur le dessus et du sucre glace
glace voilà c'est un gâteau assez simple
au sens aux amandes donc c'est pas léger
léger mais et avec du sucre glace et
durant du droit sosa qui fait le le goût
que personnellement je trouve très bon
et c'est encore ma mère qui me l'a fait
des
louis jariel déjà fait elle le faisait
et c'est elle qui me l'a fait découvrir
d'ailleurs assez tardivement bien que n
est arrivée elle à nantes en 1970 mais
c'est pas tout de suite je pense que
c'est pareil c'est un gâteau qui ont un
peu redécouvert alors que pendant
longtemps ils n'étaient pas tellement
promu à nantes et je crois que les gens
n'en faisait pas ou ne vendait pas dans
les pâtisseries encore beaucoup de
pâtisseries d'ailleurs on n'en trouve
pas alors si on avait été d'ailleurs sur
le péché mignon le pour moi le vrai
péché mignon plus que le dessert c'est
le fromage mais bon on n'avait pas en
rajouter parce qu'il faut choisir
choisi
mais alors là vous vouliez mettre en
avant nantes est donc c'est fait avec ça
avec ce gâteau là il ya des fromages
nantais aussi c'est moins connu parce
que c'est pas une région spécialement de
production désarrimée yann un curé
nantais est un fromage assez fort et qui
peut se manger de diverses façons merci
françois de rugy d'ajouter à notre
invitation